you
the first of those two problems the the
reactivity of chromosomal ends had
actually been a long-standing puzzle for
many decades and this this puzzle was
defined through the work of both Herman
Miller and Barbara McClintock in the 30s
Miller used x-rays to create breaks in
DNA and mcclintock used cytogenetic
tricks to break chromosomes but they
both came to the same conclusion which
is that those broken ends are very
reactive and do a lot of things that
normal chromosome and never do and so
this is a diagram and illustration of
the famous breakage fusion bridge cycle
explored by mcclintock and the basic
observation is that if you have a
chromosome with a broken end after DNA
replication you get two ends which join
together you now have a chromosome which
has two centromeres when the centromeres
are pulled into towards opposite poles
during cell division the DNA or the
chromosome in between is broken again
and now you get back to where you
started with so you go through cycles of
fusion and breakage and a consequence of
this is that you're spinning off cells
which have lost important parts of
chromosomes are so many dead cells that
are generated in this process and normal
chromosome ends never do this kind of
thing so it was clear that there was
something very special and different
going on at the ends of normal
chromosomes but at the time of this work
it wasn't even known that DNA was the
genetic material so they had no way to
think molecularly about what was going
on
you